amber
oh my god look at you april oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
from april hey you're not away from
april
oh tell me what's been going on you went
through hell lately
okay about a little less than a month
ago
i was somewhere not really sure where
exactly
but i had a seizure and when i got to
the hospital
i had a stroke and
now i am just right now getting out of
the rehab
rehabilitation hospital this was after
you had covert as well yeah i had covet
we yeah i talked about that before um
so i'm just getting out of the
rehabilitation hospital
but when i have my seizure
i fell pretty hard on my
and i did some damage to my spinal cord
and now they want to operate on my
spinal cord
yikes so i'm a like a little
shaky like my right side is not the best
and you might see my leg shake through
the interview yeah
i'm not having a seizure it's just your
legs are weak some of the issues from
my damage to my spinal cord um
you're walking with a cane now i walk
with the cane
i have uh they call it a
brace for my right hand so it doesn't
get
curled to kind of keep it
as regular as possible
i'm left-handed now but my parents were
left-handed
and they used to tell me don't worry
left-handed people are always right
so well this this all just happened
recently recently i've been in hospital
for three weeks
you may regain some of your hopefully
the right side it's uh
i hope that the prognosis is that
they operate on my neck and it'll
improve some of the nerve damage or some
of the damage
that was done actually i'm still working
with the neurosurgeon
and the orthopedic people to know
exactly what's wrong
i i just left today and i go back in a
couple of weeks to talk to them
but my understanding from my doctor is
that a lot of my damage
won't can't won't be i won't be back to
riot 100 or as close as that until they
do some
work on my spinal cord damage when i
fail
so
this is the bottom there's no there's
nothing left but death
no way to support yourself no way to
work the streets
no way to buy cracks yeah there's that's
over i was told
i can't have one which is a blessing
because
when anything that's um narcotic-wise
like no narcotics no
you can't don't i can't take the chance
to have one
here did cracks bring on the seizures
i would say yes my drug abuse did
because i kind of was a cocktail
drug user i did what my scene was
and um i went to rehab earlier uh
this year and i didn't last long because
i look at it now that i wasn't serious
about it
i wanted to be i thought it was but when
i got there the first time they made me
mad i left
so then i came home or came back to the
streets and i realized like whoa
this isn't what i want either so in the
process of me waiting to get a bed
and get back that's when all this
happened like for instance
honestly i was going on my on a monday
and my seizures and stroke happen on
sunday
went 24 hours before i was checking in
and what i did that weekend was like a
party
i did everything so it's no telling
exactly what
thing did it or if it was everything or
it was just god saying okay her head
you're not you're not listening let me
show you something let me show you
another way this is your last
i take it as this is my last opportunity
to get it right because after
this incident happened when the doctor
said you can't
neurologically you can't have anything
i wouldn't even suggest you smoke a
cigarette
i've never been told that i heard that
before i've heard other people say that
before
i heard in the meetings one of the
sayings was
don't even no matter what don't but now
i have a medical
professional tell me
no matter what don't you can't don't
take the chance
so i'm running to rehab
you're going to rehab tomorrow indeed
fortunately the rehab that i was going
to
um with the hospitals to help the social
workers help
they got in contact with them and they
let them know like she inflate she's in
hospital
they're giving me 24 hours from the time
i get out of
the hospital to show up and i'm going
i don't know what else to do to live you
don't really have any other choice no
i don't know what else to do to live
because i want to live i know what i
have to
i know how to kill myself simple just
take one
but i don't want to do that i want to
live i got four
five reasons to live four children and
myself
i gotta meet my kids i gotta see my kids
that's like
my biggest goal and ambition right now
is to be there for them
and i can't do it no other way but to go
into this rehab and learn how to live
sober learn how to learn how to live
again
because i forgot they doing this a long
time
and i forgot how to live i'm
asking you for some water because i'm a
little oh sure
please if you don't mind let me just get
one
thanks all right
[Applause]
okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay it's gonna be okay
we're gonna be okay
don't get nervous okay
thank you
okay so i need a little help with this
okay
sorry i've learned how to ask for help
thank you
so now i'm looking forward to living
and i just want to tell everyone that
watches the channel just don't give up
on me
i'm gonna get it together um
i'm gonna be that person that you guys
met a year ago
plus extras i'll be clean and sober
maybe i'll have a
my child with me or my children a child
at four
maybe one of my kids will see me on me
and that's time that i'll see you guys
later
but just don't give up on me and just
know that
i'm getting it together i'll i'm going
to be okay
i'm good i want to live so you're
actually going to rehab before all this
happened
yeah i was going to rehab before this
and then then all hell broke this
i was going on monday this happened
sunday you're having a little party
going away party oh yeah it was like uh
yeah i think so or or i wasn't serious
then either
because i think i've been rehab before
where i was clean for
72 days before i got there so
i would say that i wasn't serious sin
either
because if i was serious i wouldn't even
been partying i'd been focusing on
getting to that destination instead of
like the last hurrah you know
because the last hurrah almost cost me
every
the last everything so you've had
seizures before
yeah i had seizures but i think that
they were i never
went to the hospital they're always
doing my
drug use however
i'm gonna um talk to my neurologist
because there's a couple other little
things that maybe
i have epilepsy and i just never really
knew it
because i had a seizure when i was 19
when i wasn't on drugs
i just didn't go to doctor just being
hard
when you're younger teenager you think
you know everything so just like ah
that's okay i'm all right i'll go to the
doctor
just never did so i have one seizure
sober
so maybe there was something
back then that was wrong with me you
know i'm a migraine sufferer and i'd say
that that has anything to do with it but
i just i suffer from migraines and other
little things just other family history
things that
when i was 19 i wasn't caring about
being young and
and while it out i guess you'd call it
but so when i talked to my neurologist
i'm going to get real personal real
honest with them
and see because i heard that the more
honest you are with your doctor the
better it is like
you know what i mean these drugs nah you
know i don't know i don't
know i'm going to be real honest and
write down some things while i can
remember
from back then see if any of this has
anything to do with it
my future but my injury
the right side is like the stroke i'm a
my stroke was on a side that affected my
left the right
they're saying that is from my neck but
more likely it's from my
whatever i did they have a term for it
but i didn't hear it i was
crying because i kept hearing spinal
cord damage and operation
and i keep thinking about superman
christopher reed you know like
that's like the worst case scenario you
know i mean to be paralyzed from
really bad i just fearful but
at least i'll be alive right i'll be
breathing
um maybe so i'll be an example for
youth and people my age and people
yearning me and
i'm what you don't do
i'm everything you don't do because if
you do you might be like me
and i don't want that i want the best
for everybody including myself you know
i would love to see what you look like
when you get your stuff together
do your tooth fix get your i can't wait
to i just
i just want to make it i just want to
make it to tomorrow
and that's i'm not scared it's no more
next week
next year like that i really really
really just want to make sure that when
i go to sleep
i wake up to have another chance to get
life right i just want to know that i
just want chances
to get life right god just just give me
opportunity like i wanna
i wanna go to schools and speak i wanna
go to
homes where kids are speak i just wanna
speak i just wanna let everyone know
like
this is what can happen like i said way
before if you
go left this is what might happen
just keep keeps going on the right track
and just remember that
you might have it bad but i promise you
it's not that bad
and i promise you that there's someone
that has it just a little bit
worse than you and i had to learn that
the hard way i'd learn at a real
late in age but now
i'm ready to live that's how i just want
to live
i'm with god's help and and rehab
and the surgery
hopefully i hope i'm really don't want
to but i
i want to live so if it means i'm gonna
ask all those questions
if i what when what happens if i don't
but if they say something like
it'll get worse then go ahead do it
do it do it my youngest is a
six i got at least 12 more years before
he could say you know he wants to find
me and i got to make sure that i'm here
even if it means being in a wheelchair i
don't mind
i just want to be able to go breathe i
want to live
i want to live this is like i've thought
i thought i wanted to live before but
having the seizure and the stroke and
waking up two days later
and not knowing that i lost two days is
amazing
i i want to live i want to live and it's
i've thought i wanted to live but no i
want to live
okay you'll get better i'll get better i
promise i promise i'm just okay
i'm sure you will i'll be back i'll be
back guys i'll be back
all right april thank you so much for
letting me come up and talk to you
thank you thank you good luck in rehab
thank you see you soon
you